with all the latest leaks and rumors
that have been coming out i am now 100
sure that apple will be revealing the
new budget ipad 9
at their september event alongside the
new iphones
so in this video i'm going to go through
the history of leaks for the ipad 9
and explain why i'm so confident in that
date and then i'm gonna go through the
list of specs that should be coming on
this ipad
and explain why they also make the most
sense so without further ado
let's get right into it first up just by
looking at apple's ipad release timeline
you can see that for the last four years
apple's released a new budget ipad every
year
without missing a single year and
they're expected to continue this trend
this time again and if you take a closer
look apple's budget ipads usually get
released in either march or september
alongside the iphone
and since we're already into the summer
without a new ipad 9
it's gonna have to be released in
september no matter what
in fact the last two budget ipad models
were revealed
at apple's iphone event and in terms of
the date of the event itself
it almost always happens on a tuesday
and usually the second tuesday of the
month
like they did the last couple of years
so that points to september 14th
for this year's event and that's when
we're expecting the ipad 9 reveal
but now getting back to the ipad 9 leaks
and the actual specs themselves
the most important thing to understand
is that the budget ipad usually gets
updated
on a tick-tock cycle so let me explain
how that worked in the past
in 2017 apple released the ipad 5 with a
9.7 inch display
and the apple a9 champ and then the
following year
they released the ipad 6 with the same
exact 9.7 inch display
but they upgraded the chip to the a10
the year after that in 2019
they updated the design and gave it a
10.2 inch display size
but they kept the chip the same a10 as
it was before
now that was definitely a bit of a
disappointing upgrade because the new
iphone 11
was released alongside the ipad but it
came with an a13
chip three generations newer but apple
still went with the 810 for the budget
ipad and just last year
they gave us the ipad 8 with the same
10.2 inch display design
but they bumped up the chip to the a12
which means that they skipped
the a11 so as you can see the tick tock
cycle works by upgrading the design and
display one year
and then upgrading the chip the next
year so if apple were to continue this
cycle this year
we should actually expect apple to
update the design
but keep the same a12 chip as it
currently has
which would definitely be disappointing
like it was in 2019
but it shouldn't really be that
surprising if it ends up happening
but going back to the oldest leaks we
have on the ipad 9
the twitter leaker named triple zero
leaker mentioned that minchiko
expects a new low priced ipad in the
second half of 2021
with one of the prototypes being the
same design as the ipad air 3. now i
totally
agree with this because apple tends to
reuse their higher end ipad designs
for their lower end ipads for example
the 2017 ipad pro came with a 10.5 inch
display size for the base model and
the older chamfered edge design and then
in 2018
the ipad pro was upgraded to the new
modern flat edge design
with rounded corners on the display and
then in 2019
the ipad air 3 adopted basically the
same
identical 10.5 inch design that the ipad
pro
used to have and then finally in late
2020 the ipad air 4
ended up adopting the 2018 ipad pro
design
with the modern flat edges and new
display so because of that
it would totally make sense for the ipad
9 to adopt that old
10.5 inch display design as well since
it's going to be very easy for apple to
manufacture
however there are some new leaks that
just came out that point to apple
keeping the same 10.2 inch display again
for the third year in a row which would
be a bit
weird but i'll get into those reports in
just a minute now some people are hoping
for the budget ipad to also get a full
redesign
to match up with the modern ipads
complete with flat edges
no home button and a rounded corner
display
but i honestly don't think that's going
to happen because the ipad is always
behind
in terms of the feature set obviously
because
of the very cheap 329 base price for
example
the current budget ipad still doesn't
have a laminated display
it still doesn't support pci 3 white
color gamut
it still only has a 1.2 megapixel selfie
camera
it still only has bluetooth 4.2 and it
still
only comes with 32 gigs of storage at
the base price
so i expect the budget ipad to be the
very last ipad to adapt the modern full
screen design
probably at least a full year after the
ipad mini gets the new design
which is rumored to be happening this
fall now getting back to the ipad 9
leaks
in december cn beta reported that the
new ipad would be coming in spring of
2021
which was obviously wrong but they
mentioned that it would be getting a
10.5 inch display
which i can definitely see happening and
an a13
chip with four gigs of ram so basically
what they're saying
is that apple is going to break the tick
tock cycle by updating both the display
and the chip at the same time which i
think might be a possibility
but in reality the a12 chip is already
very fast
for what you're paying for the current
budget ipad with the a12
was the very first budget ipad that was
actually quite good at gaming
playing all of the best ios games out
there with ease
so apple could easily keep the a12 again
and for this
upcoming new ipad 9 i'm totally
expecting it to get a fully laminated
display
and support for dci p3 color gamut which
is actually going to be a huge deal
and it's going to make this ipad a much
better value on top of that i'm
expecting some of the other specs to get
bumped up as well
like bluetooth 5.0 and a 7 megapixel
selfie camera
so even if apple keeps the same a12 chip
it'll still be a decent upgrade
in terms of the larger thinner design
and display quality
and in that case the following ipad
update next year
could skip the a13 and go straight for
the a14 chip
without a design change like they did in
2019
and then two years from now they could
finally give the budget ipad the full
modern redesign with uniform bezels but
keep the same a14 chip now that might
seem like a ridiculously long time to
wait for the full modern redesign
but it would perfectly match up to
apple's tick-tock cycle
and you also have to keep in mind that
this is the budget ipad that we're
talking about
so in the case that this scenario ends
up happening here is my full feature in
spec list that i'm predicting
with a 329 base price just like the
current model
with 32 gigs of storage and 3 gigabytes
of ram
with the a12 chip however the only
problem i have with this scenario
is that we got a couple of reports
recently that point to the ipad 9
actually not getting an upgraded 10.5
inch display
mark german the most reliable leaker out
there said last month that the ipad 9
would be a
thinner version of the current base ipad
which will continue to be targeted to
students
on top of that mac otakara released a
report just yesterday
saying that the ipad 9 does not seem to
be any different
than the existing model so what if the
ipad 9
actually sticks to the same 10.2 inch
display
but becomes thinner than the current one
well that could actually make a lot of
sense because the current ipad's
non-laminated display
actually increases the thickness by
quite a lot
so simply swapping it out for a new
laminated 10.2 inch display
would make it quite a lot thinner and it
would match up to mark german's report
and if this does happen
that would also break the tick tock
cycle of not giving it
a new design and that would mean that we
should expect this ipad 9 to actually
get the a13
chip like others have been reporting and
i would much rather have that
than a 10.5 inch display and then that
would mean that the
full modern redesign with rounded
corners on the display
could actually come next year which
would make a ton of sense
since it's going to be the 10th
generation ipad which is perfect for a
new redesign
and if the second scenario plays out
here is my alternative list of specs and
features
complete with a 10.2 inch laminated
display
the a13 chip with 4 gigs of ram
but probably still a 329 starting price
with 32 gigs of base storage but anyway
those are the latest leaks and rumors on
the ipad 9
including my personal thoughts on the
features and the specs
and if you totally disagree with me then
go ahead and leave your comments and
thoughts
down below but if you enjoyed the video
go ahead and tap the like button and
click the circle above to subscribe
for more videos like this one definitely
check out one of those two right there
thanks for watching and we'll see you in
the next video